Hello! Did you hear about Dall-E? No, not WALL-E,
Dall-E. No, not the human painter,
the transformer-based AI painter!
Twitter exploded again because OpenAI’s new image
generation model, called Dall-E was announced.
So here we are, trying to figure out how
cool it is and how this could happen.
Image generation was already spectacular with
dedicated models used for rendering people.
There were also models for
rendering animals from textual input
but the difficulty was to generate these kinds of
images from text when the text combines concepts
and the image has to produce plausible
combinations of these concepts.
So OpenAI looked down upon the world, decided
to stop resting after publishing the great
GPT-3 and quickly solve the problem
of image generation from text too!
Yes, just like that, DALL-E was born.
And OpenAI rested the next day. Oh,
no, they should not rest because they
still have a paper to write about Dall-E.
And of course, we do not have access to the model,
so we only have OpenAIs blog post to look at.
But the situation is not new, they did
the same with GPT-3. Perhaps again a
multi-dollar company will buy exclusive rights
to the model and we will never see it again.
Ok, Ms. Coffee Bean, you were cynical enough.
So here it is: DALL-E creates images that combine
unrelated concepts in plausible ways, check.
It can also generate store front text. I
have never seen anything like this, did you?
Let us know in the comments if you did.
DALL-E can do also style transfer by a
text prompt. So it can modify the style
of an image following a textual description
of the desired output. Wow, how crazy is this?
Ok, enough showing off: what is
this model and how can it work?
DALL-E is, I cite “a 12-billion
parameter version of GPT-3
trained to generate images from textual
descriptions”. Oh, that explains everything.
No, it does not.
GPT-3 looked at text, not at images, what
do images and text have even in common?
Ms. Coffee Bean has a variety of videos on
this, trying to explain that images and text
are not that different kinds of input for
a transformer that usually works on sets.
As long as both images and text are regarded
somehow as sequences or elements in a set,
everything works again. There have been some
kinds of image sequentialization approaches in
the literature, but it is safe to assume
that OpenAI stuck to their approach from
ImageGPT, where they sequentialize
the image row by row into a 1d vector.
So now that we know how images can be sequences,
we are ready to know how DALL-E is basically
GPT-3 also looking at images. DALL-E is also a
language model that receives both text tokens and
sequentialised images as input, up to 1280 tokens.
Why is the sequence length limited to this number?
Because attention scales quadratically
and increasing the input size can
really blow up computational time.
Then like in language modelling,
the goal is to predict one token after the next.
Text tokens are words or subwords and image tokens
are image pixel values. This also means that
DALL-E does not only generate images from text,
but can also continue images if the
“beginning” of the image is already in
the prompt following the text. So that was if for
the technical details. Ok, but why does it work?
Why did the image generation problems
need specific GAN or VAE architecture to
solve the problem only partially and now
a transformer-based model can do it all?
Well, because of the formidable
amount of training data.
How much data was used exactly we do not know,
but it must have been the whole internet, like
OpenAI also did with GPT-3. And things that
were not possible with academic sized datasets,
have now become feasible with
a model that has seen it all.
This does not make the DALL-E results less
impressive, but the creativity that we see
with DALL-E has something to do with
the variance of the data it has seen.
Take this example, where they visualize
perspective and three-dimensionality. Yes,
perspective and 3D look very good in general,
but impressive for Ms. Coffee Bean is how the
model knows to make a capybara from voxels. It
becomes clear that something like this is possible
only because of all the Minecraft and other
pixel art images that the model had access to.
We would never expect from a StyleGan to
make something sensible out of the word
voxel if it has never seen these voxelized
images before in the gaming or art area
of the internet and has been limited to a
benchmark dataset of celebrity faces only. With
enormous data and variance, comes great power.
Let’s look at more showing off of this power:
OpenAI invested a lot of time into this blog-post.
Did you ever have trouble imagining a cube made
out of porcupine? Well, wait no more, here it is!
Okay, so... a cube with the texture of keyboard...
okay.
One can also draw multiple boxes
and really tell the model how to render these.
Wow, this is awesome!
Ohh, these plates are so cute!
And so smol!
Were you making a YouTube video but did not
have exactly that emoji you were imagining?
Wait no more! DALL-E is here to paint it for you!
And this is very interesting from a multimodal
perspective that one description
can have so many possible outcomes!
Wow, this is amazing, I can
play with it the whole day.
Remember the image completion example?
Well, one can even change the pose of this bust.
Okay, here are some failure cases. Interesting to
see, especially because we don't know if OpenAI
was cherry-picking in this blog post. We don't
know because we don't have access to the model.
And of course, the applications are limit-less! Do
you want to design a new t-shirt? Just tell DALL-E
how to draw it and then you have many versions of
said t-shirt on a mannequin because you introduce
the mannequin head with the image prompt and well,
you have here your designed fashion!
This has huge industrial applications! $$$
And yes, the combination of unrelated
concepts! Wow, I mean... this is... is
this art? One could ask. It made a snail into a
harp or you know... it made a harp into a snail!
And this can be creativity, one might think.
So it is exactly how they put it: it is a
3D rendering engine via natural language.
You just say what you want
DALL-E to paint and it paints it!
And you can expect the model to fill in the
blanks which means that you underspecify
your rendering instructions and the model comes
up with something. And we cannot tell for sure,
but it might just be that this something
that it fills in the blanks with is just
the most probable example that
it has seen in the training set.
Which already opens the pandora box of bias.
In the blog they promise to investigate
the societal impacts and check for
biases. Hopefully sooner than later...
Until then or until they release the model, one
can just scroll through the blog indefinitely!
But we really can not deny it, these
are impressive results from DALL-E,
bridging the gap between vision and
language, stepping into the multimodal realm.
Multimodality is my dearest
topic in Machine Learning.
Ms. Coffee Bean, what is your favourite topic?
Lalali… Oh, Ok, you do not want to tell us. Fine.
But back to DALL-E: However excited I might be
about this, I have to say, I am also a little
frustrated about all this, because throwing
the whole data of the internet at a problem
solves the the problem rather than clever tricks
and gimmicks presented so far in the multimodality
literature... you know, by ordinary mortals unlike
OpenAI. Especially as a PhD student, one has to
take these results you know... a little diluted to
still feel a little relevant in this whole system.
But, you know, everything is not done yet, future
research will tell us about the real capabilities
and problems that these model brings with them.
Also I really hope that they will keep their
promise and investigate the
societal impacts and biases.
Until then, I will keep scrolling this blog in
awe, Ms. Coffee Bean will get back to making
another video and you know... what about you?
Let us know in the comments what *you* will do
and hope to see you in the next video.
Okay bye!